yes that's right director roland
emmerich has re-established yet again
that he hates the White House White
House down where as we all know it as
diehard six or olympus has fallen part
two but here's what i gotta say this
movie exceeds the last time hard and it
exceeds olympus has fallen this movie
review is not going to be about me
comparing them to those types of films
even though there are some obvious
similarities i'm going to talk about it
just on its own merits let's start off
by talking about the number one thing
that stands out to me in this film that
is the lead actor channing [ __ ] tatum
that's is your name there's [ __ ] in
the middle of his name cft or cooked
anyway cft yes the student is every
single thing you need for a celebrity to
ever be he's funny he's extremely
charismatic he's great with the drama he
can do so much and now now he is a
badass action star some of you might be
arguing me on that same rule didn't GI
Joe rise of the Cobra do that [ __ ] you
this movie shows yes this guy could be a
huge international box office star and
yes you guys are wondering am I gonna
say it and yes I'm gonna say that penis
will be in my mouth one day another bait
standout performance in this jamie foxx
plain barack obama makes a little bit of
Jamie Foxx in there this dude is black
that is all this by far has to be the
coolest President of the United States
I've ever seen portrayed on the big
screen you know he's got his funny
Barack Obama touches here there is
obviously going for that sometimes a
little bit caricature like but that's
the cool thing about his performance he
seems to know there's a little bit of an
inside joke to it and honestly the best
moments in this film are not so much the
action but when Channing Tatum and Jamie
Foxx are sharing the screen together
their chemistry their back and forth
fantastic I wish I had a friend like
that his name is sherry on my other show
called reasons the seat there's actually
just a huge great supporting cast in
this film you got James Woods who is
looking really old I'm kind of concerned
for the guy is he ill her he's banging a
hot young chick good friend good friend
probably takes a lot about
you got Maggie Gyllenhaal even though I
know Jake Gyllenhaal is a male and his
you know cuz he's the brother to Maggie
I think Jake is a far more superior
actor compared to Maggie but she does a
really good job in the film don't know
why compared to her brother but I just
had to point that out richard jenkins is
a very very good job mr. he should get
bigger roles you know he's way more
talented than the roles that he gets I
would almost suck his dick I might touch
it but it would I don't know yeah I
don't know and Jason Clark you might
have seen from zero dark thirty or in
his cameo in the great gatsby this dude
great [ __ ] actor keep a lookout for
because he's going to be much much more
famous you know sameera boob juice and
Clark is well tell your friends about
him he needs word of mouth now how is
the thing that people are probably most
looking forward to in this movie besides
Channing Tatum's performance the action
the action and thrills and affects all
[ __ ] rock solid director roland
emmerich really knew how to make a film
but he yet again does show ya I he
doesn't like the White House I I think
he masturbates to the White House
blowing up to be honest a lot of people
don't like him they they you know they
think he just makes shitty ass films and
I'll miss some of his homes are pretty
damn shitty but this one in particular I
thought was a really solid [ __ ] a
Hollywood movie man it's got a great set
up not just a great set up at a great
act one you really feel like you get to
know all these characters it's rare
where you get a Hollywood blockbuster
where you actually really feel like you
know most of the in sambal he managed to
pull a great cast together create some
great thinners had a great
cinematographer here it's just great to
look at and the action is [ __ ]
awesome only two things stopping this
for me to rated R movie a little bit
more blood and one more character saying
the work [ __ ] sure there's some diehard
similarities but and there's a lot of
movies that have replicated a die-hard
be cheap but this one in particular is
one of the better replicas I've ever
seen and the score to the score is
cooking will take music for granted in
movies but the score is so [ __ ] good
as well and nothing to this movies
really really funny I've never thought a
movie about the White House being anal
[ __ ] could be so damn funny it would
have been funnier if josh brolin was
playing George W instead of Jamie Foxx
playing Barack Obama on stage
old-fashioned Hollywood action thriller
great hell of a time that's something
sound a little let me get straight to
the point here all in all i gotta say
white house down got it right alright
guys thanks for checking out my review
why don't you go ahead scroll that
comment box below and tell me what is
the best movie you've seen that follows
a die-hard formula and if you want to
see more depth review of white house
down go ahead and check out my shell
called reasons to see that I do have my
buddy Jerry and you want to follow me on
Twitter go ahead click the link with her
lights here last but not least if you
want to get updated every time one of my
reviews is out go ahead and subscribe to
my channel by clicking on the link right
here and if you don't roll in Emmerich
well blow up your house and the rest of
the world because he likes to do that
[ __ ] penis